I give myself just six months to prove that I can create a sustainable business. I
Understand that this is a prison but I'm finding incredibly difficult to get the prisoners out of their cells and working
because of the prison authorities stringent rules and regulations I
think part of their problem
There's so short-staffed and so for them to keep the peace and put the more time you spend in your cell makes their life easier
so they don't warn you our
Remembers, these guys are here for reasons the place can it can erupt it can go and sometimes it's over the slightest thing
And we've got to keep that under control
What users happy to cut a month so it amounts to use at that Mort might meet finger look at myself then what
Imprisoned change people trying people change it. So prison ductwork prison mark mopping. I don't come on. Okay little ass in the others
Don't fuck. Oh, thanks a dugong
No needs to work. No one needs to come and commit the system screwed here. That's the issues
The governor ed Tullett wants me to get the prisoners grafting but he admits the prison system doesn't make it easy
We things that were pretty number reasons being in a prison is a lot of things being working on the outside
But it will to get through you've got a gate to get through. You've got security systems with routines
Possible themselves reasons as they're in jail are probably the same reasons haven't got jobs in the first place
Come in guys let's go
I'm under no illusions. This lot are no angels
Before they're ready to produce lunches to sell outside prison my system GN I need to finish their kitchen training
a
Few weeks ago they couldn't even scramble an egg today. We're cooking chicken Kiev's from scratch
But not everyone in Brixton prison
appears to be taking our project as seriously as I'd like
Repeat offender test for Jones is unhappy with his treatment by the officers on the wing
I'm grimy person who's not letting you yes, so the senior officer of the wing he's safer every funnel gray
So we're not actually working. So I was there when officer Todd
That's crazy, but it is work. I need to know that just that's ridiculous
Anyone working on this prisoner gets a special time stop to go and take a shower to work it
But they're saying it's not work. You're having fun. Yeah. No. All right
I thought the office would be in support of them. But on the opposite way
If Tesla has been singled out for the wrong sort of special treatment I need to talk to the officers concerned I
Want them to see this is not a jolly and
Feedback your sight. They are absolutely head down and they are grafting in there. They tell me that a lot
I don't know half the summer don't believe it. They tell me push that brew up and down the ladder
They're working very hard, you know? Yeah. No, but they said that they weren't getting showered last week, too
Nice in the trot, and this isn't fair
They do know I'm struggling because there's issues when they come back on the wing that they complain about you guys
They treat us like shit
They think we're on special privileges not work the officers don't think we work in so they take us
Down the realms of winding us up. No, I can tell you that more important things to do them
Yeah, I can say that no one goes out their way to wind them up
Are they starting to piss you off a couple of them think they're superstars was the Germans specifically
Yeah came in over the other day shouting the odds. He wants a shower
Calling me all those and the Sun pussy hole and God knows what?
Yeah, if someone comes to me and I tell them three times
They can't have a shower a shout and screen and call me names. Then. There's very little I can do about that
frustrating
Yeah
Appreciate your time. I'll Cooper. I know these officers are doing their best under enormous pressure
but they have a very different take on events to test for I
See him working more than they see him working. They see him Stephen. I see him working
So, you know, we got to meet in the middle
and I'm not gonna take everything as crew says 100% go in there and lay into them know that because
I'm back to square one the prisoners back to square one the systems back to square one and in ten years time
We're still in this shit situation. So
It's a fucking nightmare. I mean it really is right now on the fourth floor here
Yeah, I feel like the governor's bitch. No, don't do something we can't do and I'm not dead toilets, bitch